he decided to launch an expanded asset
purchase program encompassing the
existing purchase programs for asset
backed securities
paint cover bonds under this expanded
program the combined monthly purchases
public and private sector securities
will amount to sixty billion euros they
are intended to be carried out until in
September 2016 and will in any case be
conducted until we see a sustained
adjustment in the path of inflation
which is consistent with our aim of
achieving inflation rates below but
close to 2% over the medium term in
March 2015 the euro system will start to
purchase euro denominated investment
grade securities issued by euro area
governments and agencies and European
institutions in the securities market in
the secondary market the purchases of
securities issued by euro area
governments and agencies will be based
on the euro system national central
bank's shares in the ECB's capital key
some additional eligibility criteria
will be applied in the case of countries
under an EU IMF adjustment program